will it hold
last few times it kept telling me
that it was disconnecting and this and
that and the other i'm
ah
so i'm in a
i'm in an irritated mood now
so let me just
clean this up give me a second hi
how is everybody uh
hopefully better than me
i don't do well when um
when things go wrong and i don't
understand why
and like there's absolutely no reason
for them to i'm just going to adjust
this a little bit
i feel about that i gotta i gotta lower
the
brightness on this i'm still fiddling
with this lighting setup for the
purposes of streaming
oh for god's sake
huh all right i think that's better
huh you've been fiddling with it yes i
have
renee uh
so thankfully i have eggnog
on hand
oh did you have a good thanksgiving last
week i did
i had a very nice thanksgiving um
thankfully
uh ours wasn't um really very disrupted
by kovid because nobody comes in from
out of town or out of state or even
really from other like thanksgiving is
me and my daughter's mother and like
there were people who are regularly in
contact anyways
so nobody who was not um
in our basically immediate sphere of
contact
came to thanksgiving or normally does
and suddenly couldn't so we had a pretty
standard thanksgiving
uh all things considered
what's your favorite and least favorite
thanksgiving dish
ooh okay
see the thing is i'm actually inclined
to mashed potatoes
um which can be had at any time but
i don't know i almost never get to have
them outside of thanksgiving
so that's what probably my favorite my
least favorite
um it used to be stuffing
until i have my kids mother stuffing
which is amazing i didn't like
most of the stuffing i had prior to that
um
i don't know i know a lot of people have
like shrimp cocktail as like an
appetizer
[Music]
but there's there's nothing at uh that
my thanksgiving that i don't like
thoughts on elliot page okay i'm i'm
i'm saying rushing i don't mean like i'm
not gonna do a good job but i'm gonna
try
but i am throwing together a
video on the topic and dealing with the
sort of questions that i see
already coming up a lot so i'll talk
about that a little bit here
but i'll probably not get into it too
deeply because like i said i'm i'm
pulling stuff together
like to actually do a video on him
short version congratulations to elliot
paige
and i hope that there is minimal
dickishness
towards him as uh as this stuff
goes on there will be some there will
always be some
but you know i've definitely got things
to talk about
uh you might remember i used to be
semi-reactionary you might also be aware
i'm full on leftist now
well that's in part because of you so
thanks you're welcome
the sjw's we recruit
got a little overzealous and drooled a
little
i really suddenly i recently finished
the sarah jane adventures and i wish
elizabeth sladen could have lived to see
the first female doctor that would have
been nice yeah
um so general heads up in the past i've
tried to keep up
with the questions and like i've
scrolled back up to get questions i
missed
i'm i'm not up for that today
so if i missed your question and it
scrolls past
ask it again but don't spam the chat
you know just there's there's a balance
to be struck here
rudolph is on tonight on cbs at 8 are
you watching no i don't
i don't have normal tv i just stream
i also didn't grow up with that i was 20
by the time i saw rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer so for me it's mostly an
oddity is eggnog alcoholic it is if you
make it right
have you played villainous i don't even
know what that is
what are your thoughts on the haunted
mansion 2003
look as somebody who loves not only
the haunted mansion ride but i have i
grew up with and i still
have a record
and yes i have a record player that was
an audio
dramatization of the haunted mansion
and i love it so much
the there's this um there's this
host the ghost host who's
leading these teenagers through the
mansion and sort of the same set pieces
that you actually see when you go to the
attraction
and it yes it's cheesy but i love it and
that movie just doesn't
it doesn't know what it's doing
yeah thoughts on sister act i haven't
rewatched it in a really long time
i remember liking the music though i've
seen the stage version
they don't use the same kinds of songs i
guess because they would have had to pay
for the rights because a lot of those
were like
mashups of uh existing
songs and sort of you know with more
religious tinges and they decided when
they to make it a stage version they
just make original songs so they don't
have to pay
rice fees to anybody but like
it ain't the same but it's not as good
also there's a terrible romantic subplot
uh in the stage version of sister act do
you like little shop of horrors
yeah i do um i don't love it but i do
like it
lots of que lots of questions about
musicals
did i accidentally let slip that one of
the things i'm working on is
is a top 10 musicals movie musicals
list because like
you're starting to spook me out here
oh yes miss wicked wolf that yes
i loved that so okay this is probably my
favorite moment
in the original audio version in my
record
of um haunted mansion ham
so there's this point where the
teenagers are led
into this room with no windows and no
doors the way they came in just slides
close behind them
and the voice in in this sort of
slow echoing thing so you know there's
effects on it and whatnot
um it's um give me a second i'm gonna
i want i want to get this line right so
just give me a second on it
your logic cannot deny that this
chamber has no windows
and no doors
which offers a rather logical challenge
defined a way out
there's always my way
at which point there is a um a bolt of
lightning and they see a
corpse from a noose
on out of the ceiling i love it
so much ah
makes me very happy
top 10 musicals number one wreck your
picture show don't even correct
me if it's not here's the thing like i
know what
i know what movie musicals i'm going to
put on the list i have not figured out
an order for them yet that's actually
going to be
really hard on this one
what's your problem with romantic
subplot
95 of stories don't benefit from it
it doesn't buoy the existing story it
doesn't feed into the primary existing
themes it's just something that's done
because it's an expectation
i don't have an inherent hatred of
romance i just hate the way it is
injected into
damn near everything just because
can i s can i get this to sort the
give me a second here let me just try oh
no
hang on just seeing if any of this sort
of
sorts out my lighting a little bit
nope okay forget this
silly filters nonsense
do you watch robot chicken i used to i
haven't known a long time i do not
remember the last time i watched uh an
episode of robot chicken
gratuitous yes excellent excellent word
that describes the vast vast vast
majority of romantic subplots
you look good in sepia oh thank you
darling
what's the worst movie musical i've ever
seen
it's awful but i'm also going to
recommend that people watch actually
i've got
two and i cannot decide which is worse
it would either be
can't stop the music which is the movie
musical about the formation
of the village people
oh boy starring oh
god steve guttenberg
or um
the apple which is this bizarre
80s thing that is trying to be
like the garden of eden story mashed up
with
what was current at the time music
behind the scenes culture it's freaking
awful
like it's bizarre enough to be kind of
interesting but it's really bad
have you seen the fault in our stars i
know i have not
do how do i identify i identify as a
human being i know i identify as gender
fluid so if you're asking pronouns i use
she or they
either one is acceptable not cats cats
is in the running but i mean like the
thing is i feel bad
knocking on cats too much because i
fundamentally don't get
cats even the stage version i don't get
it
and but i know a ton of people get
something out of it that i
don't she identifies as a threat
i do love that line i can't remember if
i've used that one on tick-tock i don't
think i have
i might have a draft that uses it
somewhere
have you seen the lego with star wars
holiday special no i want to
like here's i even like
sat down to just watch something that
wasn't something i needed to watch
related to the channel in weeks
it's
oh god i never have time for stuff
anymore
i'm juggling so much and like it's my
own doing
let me be very very very clear about
that
i did this to myself and it's
ultimately it's what's best for me i
need to keep busy but
yeah maybe i'll have some breathing room
once the book's done
we'll see
who do you think should replace johnny
depp and fantastic piece three wasn't
mads mikkelsen confirmed
i believe he was um
of course the apple is bad it's a canon
movie hey i will defend
masters of the universe and that's a
canon movie so
have you heard of the fellow youtuber dr
freedom i have not i am not familiar
i finally finished my short film script
it's a dark comedy with an occultist
going to hell with time travel
mechanics that
that sounds like a lot
i use the pronoun they them whenever i
discuss you with my friends don't know
why
i mean it's easier
it's that's fine it's
it's listed as an acceptable pronoun
because it is
uh do you know the actor ben platt
not that i know of you you if you list
some things that he's
been in i might recognize some of those
but i don't recognize the name
with the recent problems with the lgbtq
plus rep and live action stuff recently
could you do a video
how animated shows have been absolutely
crushing it
here's the thing i don't think the
reason those shows are doing it better
is because they're animated i think the
reason they're doing it better is
because they're fantasy
so here's what i mean by that
when anything is set in a
fantastical world it gets to make its
own rules
about what is normal
but anything that you make that is set
in the
real world the expectation is there is
going to be some acknowledgement of
the difficulties that exist in the real
world of family rejecting you of
people not understanding and the case of
trans people of being misgendered and
things like that
and there's i i think there's kind of a
fear
um among some writers and directors and
creators that if they
ignore all that it's somehow less
realistic
whereas if you set something in a
fantasy world like shiro which i love
and
owl house which i'm enjoying and i'm
still working my way through so no
spoilers here
but with something like shira which is
set on a completely different planet
and all these queer characters nobody
ever says the words gay
or lesbian and no one ever questions
any of the characters who have same-sex
attractions or
any of it because it's clearly not an
issue
in this world and when you create your
own world you can create a world like
that
like i said when you have something that
is in the real world
you could do that but
it feels like creators don't have the
wherewithal to decide to try and do that
maybe there's a belief that audiences
wouldn't accept it i don't know if
anybody's
tried so who knows whether or not that's
been
tested actually um
and and the other thing even with some
things like say
star trek which is in theory a made-up
world with its own rules that has
decades worth of baggage about how they
were portraying things before that it
still has to
deal with have you seen the london
revival of gypsy i have not i've only
ever seen a community theater production
of gypsy which was quite good
um i believe it was the stow players
uh central vermont something i do
uh someone something i do is look for
good ideas and concept because to me
nothing is inherently bad just poorly
implemented
i would argue that some things
okay here's what i will say there is no
idea that cannot be done well
but there are some ideas that the margin
for
being able to do it well is
about as thick as a nat's wing
let's go with that
uh
do you think jody whitaker's uh finale
will be the 60th anniversary special i
have no idea
i kind of hope not because um
i want the anniversary special just to
be a celebration i think bringing
regeneration baggage to that won't
i'm not sure how well that'll blend
that's just my gut talking if that's
what they do that's what they do
um
thank you the closest thing i have to a
romantic subplot in my project is one of
the characters has a thing
for another but she doesn't give him
enough thought to even notice
oh the unrequited he was in dear evan
hansen pitch perfect 102 the book of
mormon netflix original the politician
also i probably would have seen him in
the first pitch perfect
i haven't seen any of the rest of those
though and most of the male characters
in pitch perfect were
really forgettable oh uh somebody
mentioned the shirt
this is actually my merch um
excuse me while i plug my own stuff for
a minute uh
the beautiful valid love the the colors
on this
uh on the one i'm wearing are the gender
fluid pride colors
uh if you go to my tee public store
which there should be a link in the
description
i have this available in 16 different
pride colors so
be it for yourself or for a loved one i
think
hopefully i've got everybody covered um
and if i missed one feel free to tell me
i'll get it made
have you still been watching inside
number 9 no i only ever did that first
series
i haven't had the time to go back and do
more of it and i didn't have an
inclination to do it
with my free free time
oh that's good
since you got brib box you need to watch
spitting image adding more things
to my uh
to my to-do list like that's
uh that's funny
excuse to plug or excuse to plan at your
own breasts
both both both is good
did you like dave the doctor and did you
see it in the cinema
at an event or at home i saw it at home
and i do like it i like it pretty well
have you seen anything by bennett the
sage
not a clue who that is so that would be
a no
are there any instances where a romantic
subplot works for you
i off the top of my head no
um i mean there probably are but like
really only if it factors into the
theming that's otherwise going on in the
thing
i mean that's why i hate it in things
like
um like action movies very few action
movies benefit
from that kind of thing thank you very
much joshua
love your vids uh how do you think the
classic doctors would react to jack
flirting with them i think
six would probably be all for it i think
i think six will probably be okay would
boost his ego
i don't think the first doctor would
notice that that's what he's doing
um second doctor will probably just be
confused
[Music]
third doctor might actually just match
his energy
a fourth doctor would just sort of smile
and not
bring it up fifth doctor i i expect
would ignore it
seventh i don't know how the seventh
would react to that
and i suppose that serves that over my
another selfless plug like i like i said
i'm trying to grab
comments as i see them but if you want
to ensure that i see your comment
the super chat is an option all of those
will be read otherwise
it's a bit of a dice roll
what are your thoughts on fraggle rock i
only ever watched it a little bit
when i was a kid um
i mean it's jim henson so like it's fine
i don't have a lot of strong memories of
it though aside from the theme song
pretty sure action movies do that to
appeal to the male audience the male
audience is already there to watch
crap get blown up
and like let me be clear i'm not talking
about scantily clad women which
can be its own issue like i get that
feeding to the mail thing
but actually stopping the frigging story
or having the the hero do something that
they otherwise
would not do to save
their romantic love interest just stop
uh find a more interesting way to up the
stakes
uh have you watched blackadder i have
i have seen uh although i skipped the
first
uh series i've seen all the rest i never
did see the first one because i was told
to skip it
how's your daughter uh she's doing
pretty well you know she's
in school well she's in school about
half the time
and we'll see how long that holds
um things are getting um
close down a little bit around here
like everywhere it's i mean it's still
not too bad
as as far as things go
excuse me uh vermont is one of the
states
with some of the better numbers but you
know it's still
gotten worse from what it was so you
know it's a thing
i wish i had a friend like you and my
well first of all thank you cleopatra
i wish i had a friend like you in my
life someone who just gets it
i'm tired of having to explain my
transness uh
or validate it even to friends
i mean i um i hesitate to say that i
just got it like i am
i got here by
38 years of life experience so at this
point it is
fairly intuitive to me but it's because
i've lived it
i'm not sure i would just get it
otherwise and i know it's exhausting to
make allowances for people
to a certain extent you have to but then
again you don't give them
infinite leeway either
um how far am i into owl house i episode
seven eight something like that thoughts
on terry pratchett favorite book i've
only read
to date two terry pratchett books i've
read
uh the monstrous regimen and i've read
good omens
um i actually have been commissioned
to read guards guards but i've
um i've got i've got another book i was
commissioned to read before that plus a
bunch of other stuff so like
it's on my to-do list it'll happen
eventually
but um i know i i couldn't tell you
right now
when that is i have seen hogfather i
have not read it
thank you very much thomas do you think
they should introduce a new companion to
replace grammar ryan or just have the
doctrine yes carry the show just the
doctrine yes
i think the the lack of a central and
core um doctor companion relationship
is one of the things that at least for
me
has been hurting whitaker's run and i
want to just see them
strengthen that don't add more
people please ah
um have you seen anything by martin
scorsese like goodfellows or casino i've
only seen a couple of martin scorsese
films i'm trying to think now
um i've seen most of casino
i've seen most of goodfellas like and
these are things like i've caught
by osmosis i don't think i ever sat down
and
um and watched them love the tardis here
they're
actually what they are they're bombs
um i've seen the departed which i like a
lot
um i've seen
shutter island which i didn't like very
much at all and i think is
drastically overrated i still see it
show up on like lists of
best psychological throws i'm like this
is crap
that movie's garbage like it's pretty
it's well filmed it's shot a lot better
than a lot of movies like that are but
it's
garbage movie we need donna we always
need more donna
have you heard about the traumatizing
movie megan is missing that's going
around i
have not heard of that
favorite guilty pleasure movie um
i don't know i've got a small collection
of them so like
some things on the list would include
g.i joe rice of cobra
masters of the universe um
[Music]
i had one in my head a second ago and i
lost it oh uh house on haunted hill
the um the remake with jeffrey rush
what's the best big finish box set
you've listened to i haven't listened to
all that many of the box sets
honestly i prefer the one offs i prefer
the main range i'm a little bummed out
that they're ending it
as far as the box sets go the one i've
liked the best was
the war master uh only the good
that was oh yeah that was good stuff
uh what's something important your
daughter explicitly taught you
oh oh dang
um
uh
patience more than anything else
i guess um sort of along the specifics
of that
um knowing you're right
doesn't mean you get to be impatient
with someone who doesn't understand
why you're right
i'm sad that graham in particular is
leaving i'm looking forward uh
for a better character development of
yes yeah i mean that's what i have my
fingers crossed for
who's your favorite classic who
companions so far oh jamie
oh it's jamie and ace it's oh it's close
it's real close
if i did a list of tv moments that made
me cry the final episode of blackadder
is in there
specifically the moment when george
admits he's scared
yeah that was that was uh surprisingly
poignant
do you think raymond and ryan will be
killed by daleks or lead by choice i
really hope they just leave by choice
because i i'm really kind of over having
this
thing where only the only way anybody
leaves is because they're forced out
we haven't had someone just decide to
leave the tardis since
martha and she's really the only one of
the modern era who's done that
have you watched crazy ex-girlfriend not
only have i watched it i cited it in a
video from late october on uh depictions
of mental health
i love your tick tock thank you uh can
okay can i just take a second
to say how
weird like
my success i get quote unquote on tick
tock is
so like i've been on tick tock since
may wasn't really doing much
with it seriously until like i don't
know
september maybe um
and i have more followers on there
than i have subscribers here
i actually have more followers there
than i have subscribers
on all of my channels here combined
which is weird
it's like it's it's fine but it's
it's really weird
then ah there are people who are gonna
know me from that who don't even know i
do youtube it's so
it's so strange uh my life is
becoming surreal in ways that
i'm kind of enjoying but it's like
update from last life well thank you
cara first of all
um significant others bigender uses they
them pronouns though
uh i'm the only one they're out to um
and honestly that's massively important
that
they were comfortable coming out to you
because the thing is the people
say you know coming out as if it's
something you only do once
it's something you are going to keep
doing that they
are going to keep doing because they've
come out to you
eventually they will come out to other
members of their family
or friends if uh
hopefully if the comfort level is there
they will come out
um to co-workers and social media why
not but it's a continual
process but that process is
easier once you have that first person
in your corner who supports you
and you get to be that for them and that
is wonderful
thank you very much renee any comments
on the crown
especially in regards to thatcher do you
think clause 98
should have been shown uh anti-lgbt bill
um i don't watch the crown so i actually
don't know
anything about what you're talking about
based off the question i'm going to
assume
that it's avoiding
it's depicting thatcher while avoiding
the policies that she put forward or
some of the or some
specific ones at any rate which
the uh the movie about her also did
which is is cowardly
if you're gonna talk about someone's
impact on the world and their legacy
you you need to look and i was gonna say
you need to deal with the good and the
bad but the thing is
from her perspective this stuff wasn't
bad this was what she wanted to
accomplish
so it's not even like oh well we don't
want to talk about the bad times as far
as she was concerned
most of what she did was good
so i don't know who they think they're
sparing
if they make the decision to not depict
that
if captain jack doesn't meet 13 in the
special i will unleash my
inner caring i would be stunned if they
don't actually meet
uh hello from germany hello there also
have you seen
the venom movie if so what did you think
i did
i think there's a review on this channel
i had fun with it i didn't have very
high expectations which
helped but it was it was fun i'm
actually kind of excited for the
sequel i want to see what they do with
it
what are your thoughts on kingdom hearts
i only played the first two
um well no that's not true i played the
first two and chain of memories
by the time i beat the second one i was
like this the lore
on this is getting preposterous and like
even just out of the corner of my eye
catching what's been going on the
franchise since then i'm like
no that's this
pass even if i had a machine that could
play
kingdom hearts 3 hard pass good grief
but there was something really magical
about that first time playing the
original kingdom hearts
it's it's hard to put into words what it
was like but it
there was something really special about
that
um you know you've got a problem when
you get drunk and wake up
with three advent calendars in your room
with every door open
uh been on that date
uh do you listen to the hamilton
soundtrack even when you're not running
i haven't lately
um that was the main situation which i
was reading because uh lately i've
gotten into the soundtrack to
six uh if you haven't heard that i do i
do recommend it
it's about the uh the six wives of henry
viii
it's fun
where did sasha dwan fall in your master
ranking i don't know
because i kind of want to see um more of
the fallout from the timeless child and
i know the
timeless child is the doctor but the
fact that the master
was the one who found that out and
brought it to her attention i i feel
like i need to see
more about how he's gonna handle all
this before i can make a call on him
thoughts on the rocky your remake never
saw it didn't care to wasn't interested
uh what time of the day do you go
running well i don't really as much now
because it's gotten cold i usually try
and do it in the morning
um like late morning so apparently when
i'm drunk i
hit the notes for you'll be back
perfectly
speaking as a 19 year old bisexual i'm
really hoping yaz turns out to be gay bi
or queer in some way
and even more so uh not in a cast deal
uh just about to die away oh yeah
yeah you should watch them react to
doctor and just stress okay how many of
you are
in on this on this little
coven of people keep pushing me to watch
and react to this thing
part of me is tempted just to just to
delay
and delay just to string you along see
how many of you come out of the woodwork
uh do you like roller coasters i have to
be in the right mood but yeah
yeah i have fun with those kingdom
hearts drinking game take a shot
whenever
they say heart light or darkness you
will be dead by the end of the tutorial
uh what are your thoughts on forrest
gump i haven't seen it a
long time um so i actually don't even
know how well it holds up
uh the actor who plays sam swift also
played the meddling
monk uh in the missy box set you might
have actually been the one somebody
commented that
um when i when the review for that
episode went up i
which i didn't realize which makes
sense covet yes carowind
coven was the first word that came to my
mind i cannot imagine why
or casino royale oh skyfall casino
royale is good but it's
clunky the the three acts
of it are so distinct and they're almost
like from completely different movies
they don't flow well one to the other
even though each self-contained
is quite good
if you continue the war master series or
do the 50th anniversary master story
um which i have done that i have
reviewed that one
um there's another unbound story you
should check out somebody for the devil
david warner plays the doctor
i did hear about well and also thank you
very much the sentinel i appreciate that
i did hear about that and that is one of
the ones i'm certainly curious about
have you ever done will you ever do a
missy cosplay
yes yes i will
when i'm not on a spending freezing can
afford cosplay items again
that i mean the thing is this is why
this is my living now because
i cut expenses i cut them to the bone
and you better believe i cut fun
expenses which like even with something
like that which
i could honestly if i appear in it in a
video i could write it off
on my taxes but i still have to pay for
it up front in the first place
which i'm i'm not i made a decision
for until i get my car
paid off which if i
if i'm lucky will happen next year but
until that
happens i'm really not
doing fun purchases i'm just not
um you know things that that i don't
absolutely
need even if i could theoretically write
them off
because that's still money i shouldn't
be spending now
uh who's the council accountant
i don't know if you if you if this has
gone beyond tick tock but there's a
whole
thing there where with um well honestly
anyone who makes their living in
unconventional ways but primarily sex
workers there was a song
that made its way around
um that when people
ask me what i do when people ask you
what you do just say that you're an
accountant
what do you do i'm an accountant where
do you work at a place where accountants
work
um but that having been said
i do have my amazon wishlist in the
description and i do have a missy
cosplay piece
on there so if you desperately want to
see me in it
and you don't want to wait for me to be
able to afford to start buying cosplay
pieces again
i'm just saying i'm s
i'm oh man no
i i stopped myself saying i'll say i am
a [ __ ] tonight i am whoring myself out
argor and no shame on that you get your
money however you get it
thank you very much renee the new
chromecast
is cheap as chimps i didn't realize
chips were chimps were cheap
these are hard words to string together
you are a professional geek i know
right
discord ah yes caroline thank you i will
get to that in a second
do you like brie larson i i've liked her
in most of the movies i've seen her in
if you're asking if i like her outside
of the movies i have no comment on her
as a person um
so okay let me grab this super chat and
then i'll pop over
to the discord which is the other way to
guarantee that your questions
will be answered um let's see
excuse me thank you very much mr will
guitar
uh bravo for your career choice great
courage and inspiration best wishes and
thanks for all your reviews
still think you dig the 1977 hulk
without wishing to labor the point
uh and add to the workload i
if i can um
get into you know the vibe of it
i probably would
are you trying to watch shit's creek
again i've seen the first couple
episodes
um i watched them with liz because she
started watching it anyway i gotta hop
to the discord
which as a reminder yes there is a
council of geeks discord but it is a
patreon perk
so if you wish you were on there and
participating in conversations with
other council members about all things
geeky um
that's that's where that would be so let
me just pull that up see what i've got
on here
uh as we are heading into december what
is your favorite
santa on screen big or small could nick
frost take richard
attenborough or edward gwynne
sorry edmund gwynne
nick frost is a really nice and unique
santa i do enjoy him a lot
honestly i also like the the tattooed
santa from
rise of the guardians i don't know if i
could name a favorite
there are some good ones though and i
kind of like richard attenborough a
little bit more than edm and gwen
edwin's good it's classic iconic even
but
question how do i get into star trek i
tried next generation because i heard
it's the best show i saw the first
episode
i did like q but it didn't catch but it
just didn't catch me outside that
performance here's the thing i actually
don't know how to answer that right now
so here's the thing next generation is
generally considered to be the
best or one of the best shows but
first season is rough
first season almost the entirety of it
is not very good
even the second season there isn't that
much is good about it it doesn't get
good until
a bit later on so
um honestly
i'd say try some of the movies just to
see if you
vibe with it or not so try
wrath of khan you do search for spock
it's not bad
definitely do voyage home do the
undiscovered country
do first contact or even try the reboot
ones
and figure out what you're vibing with
um and then sort of go from there it is
a bit like doctor who which is basically
like
don't start you don't have to start at
the beginning you can you don't have to
pick an
error and get it get your head wrapped
around that but if you're not
vibing with it try another era try
another show
um i haven't seen all of them is the
other thing i've seen bits and pieces of
most of them i still haven't seen any of
discovery i think that's the only one i
haven't seen
any of the rest of at least in parts
whilst i find both to be overrated is it
odd that i prefer
the shiny over 2001 a space odyssey
i would expect that's a matter of
personal taste i actually don't like
either one
the middle third of 2001
is brilliant
the first act in the third act
i'd i don't care
i agree with stephen king when it comes
to the shining but the thing is stephen
king's objections
basically came down to you changed my
book i don't recall him making very
substantive
um you know
concerns about why it doesn't work as a
film it was just they changed my book
and i think and like i've never read the
original so my issues with the shining
aren't even as an adaptation
i just think it's not a good movie all
right i am popping on back
and so now i'm i'm here again and i have
you read accession yet
uh if yes one is a review coming i have
started it
it's a thick book and i am juggling a
lot
i'm working on it personally i will
never understand
people's problems with the venom movie
to me
all that it had was some pacing issues
and that's it
it had some patient issues and its
villain sucked
it was a lousy lousy villain honestly
the main thing it had going for it was
the bond between eddie and venom that
was where the fun
was
if there's ever a sweeney todd revival
you should play the title character i
would love to play sweeney todd
oh
that there's a hole in the world like a
great black pit and it's filled with
people who are filled with
[ __ ] and the vermin of the world
inhabits it
but not for long
uh don't know if it's popped up at all
but thoughts on the female bond well
first of all
like i feel like that gets misreported
all over the place
my uh understanding is that
they're talking about a female 07 that's
not the same as a female bond it's not
like james bond is now a woman double 07
is just
a rank it's it's just a specific
agent designation so there's no reason
that it couldn't be a woman
and so on that level mike whatever
they're not changing james bond into a
woman they're
having other uh like the concept is
another character gets to be double07
but james bond is still james bond
i don't know the whole conversation is
weird to me as the founder of the doctor
in distress coven
i do apologize if the requests get
irritating i'm still having fun with it
if it gets genuinely irritating you'll
know because i won't smile when i talk
about it
it'll be more like this
so unless you see that i'm probably okay
uh if there's an into the woods broadway
revival
who would you play i don't know into the
woods that i mean i've seen it
but like i saw it god like 20 years ago
um and i wasn't into it enough to like
really dive into the soundtrack or
anything like that so
i i don't even know um did you like
the sequel to six or do you think
changing the main cast
genre medium was too drastic i didn't
realize six had a sequel
i was unaware uh have you played any
games
by platinum games specifically bayonetta
or wonderful 101 nope
i've never played a platinum game
uh so like when anyone
when anyone was a timeless child uh i
suppose
ever been tempted to use those axes of
yours in the background
no because i know that's crap metal and
it's decorative
if i actually wanted to do some damage
i'd go for the cutlass
that one's actually a sturdy piece of
equipment
um well you can't see it from there
though hold on
if i actually found myself in a position
where i needed to grab something
it'd be this not the axe
although i suppose the spike bit on it
would be all right but the actual axe of
the blade like
i i couldn't cut anything with that
like it would only just be however much
force i could put behind it
thank you very much cleopatra i know you
dislike a lot of negative
queer tropes but the [ __ ] villain is my
guilty pleasure because they're so
fabulous
riddler to silva etc so like i talked
about this
um when i talked about gay coding
last year i think was that video
um and the simple fact is
whether they are explicit or not
i think the reason gay coding hasn't
left villains
is that it's gay-coded villains are fun
they're really really fun i mean just
look at the
snark from someone like scar
oh i shall practice my curtsy oh
that's just fun so like i get and like i
say that understanding that
the excessive use of
queer coding on villains can be a
problem i actually think it's become
less of a problem than it used to be
as more representation happens then
the fact that they sometimes get um
these traits and coding signifiers get
lumped onto villains
doesn't matter as much when there's
plenty of non-villain representation
out there it was actually a bigger
problem a few decades ago
when queer coded villains was the
majority of queer representation
that's not the case as much now so
i actually think there's less of an
issue
with gay coding your villain as long as
you are not
in some way doing it so that it seems
like it is their
gayness that makes them villainous so
unless you unless you trip over that
hurdle
i i don't think it's as big of an issue
as it once
was at least in terms of damaging
um you know perceptions or whatever
as a piece of representation uh now i
say that
largely in terms of gay coding
transcoded villains that's
actually still kind of a of an issue
because there isn't um
quite as much trans representation in
other areas to balance it out
do you think 13 will be okay with jack's
advances i kind of see her as
aggressively asexual especially compared
to 11 the most sexualized doctor
um
i kind of want her to to ignore
like every time he makes a pass at her
because like you know jack he he rarely
he at least when talking with the doctor
he would rarely hit on the doctor
if he wasn't already saying something
like he'll bring this up and
add a flirt into it i kind of want to
see the 13th doctor address whatever the
first thing was and ignore the flirt
just ignore it every time
queer-coded villain morrissey
isn't marcy a singer i think i'm missing
something here
do you watch aqua teen hunger force i
used to occasionally
um back in the day i think i kind of
grew out of it
a problem i have with the live-action
disney remakes is they take out a lot of
the songs
i feel like could work in the
live-action setting so like
here's the thing about that logan
leaving the songs in pisses off people
like me
so this is a case if you can't please
everybody now i will grant in most cases
those songs are a big part of what made
the originals great
but by re by bringing the songs in and
using them again
like they did with things like the lion
king
or with beauty and the beast then that
to me
invalidates as to why the hell this
movie should even exist in the first
place
because you didn't make a new movie you
didn't even adapt your earlier version
you just made it again
songs and all you stripped the identity
from an anime thing and did it live
action what is the point
removing the songs and attempting to
tell a story without them
at least gives some validation
as to what you're attempting to do
because you're not using the same
mechanisms and the same beats
specifically that were used in the
previous version so you
have to do something at least slightly
different
or find a different way to communicate
with the songs communicated
does that mean that the movies where
they've done that like cinderella
or mulan are actually any good no it
does
not but it really like this is why this
entire trend
is awful it's a terrible idea
to the bone marrow because you're either
going to piss off people who
wish it to be more like the original or
you're going to piss off people like me
who are annoyed at how much of the
original you just recycled
stop doing it
what sort of weapons do you like i like
swords especially japanese
um european and japanese i like a lot of
them aesthetically for personal use
longbow i'm actually quite good with the
longbow
you missed the chat deciding that we
wanted a vera stream musical
uh here's the thing
i okay
here's what here's what i'll say
the main reason i don't sing more
on this stream is because
i know from experience if i sing too
much
it gets caught by the copyright bots and
then monetization gets shut down
on the playback and it kills the chat
and you can't replay the chat which
if you're going to watch a live stream
back you kind of need to be able to have
that
but um
on tick tock that's not a concern
i'm not worried about the archived
version
of a live because if you go live on tick
tock it's
you're just there for however long
you're live and you know me
unless somebody screen captures it it's
gone once you're done
so if i were to sing more
and it was things that were copyrighted
copy written copyrighted i don't know
i could get away with that on a live
tick tock that i could that i
opt to not push my luck with here
just thinking out loud
not sure if you've answered this before
favorite six song mine was heart of
stone
i find a heart of stone to be boring
um i'm partial to all you want to do
because i love the arc of that song um
i mean there's a reason it sits six
minutes long it's actually telling the
story of like her
experience and like she's so and she's
so frustrated by the end of it
it's um i like that one a lot
i'm trying to get my girlfriend to watch
torchwood because she adores jack
but she can't get into it past the
second episode
um well first of all that second that
second episode
almost got me to stop watching torchwood
that episode day one
is terrible it's
awful it is so bad
ah so like i don't
blame her uh
how did this go from the most wonderful
time to i need a stiff drink uh because
i had a crap ton of problems getting the
thing even to go live that was why
um so
and here's the other thing i'm not the
person to get recommendations for on
torchwood
because i don't like most of torchwood
i like sporadic bits
here and there the only
season i liked consistently
was children of earth but i'd be
hesitant to leap her in on that because
she might hate you for it
because that thing is so freaking
dark
like it's great but damn
hmm
hypothesizing that copyright wouldn't be
an issue what are some songs you'd sing
on a cover album ah see like i haven't
actually thought about that
now now i've got to start to ponder that
what song would each doctor sing at a
karaoke bar
oh i don't know but someone needs to put
together a cosplaying doctor's
compilation of
of all the doctors doing karaoke
oh that'd be so good okay shoot yeah all
you want to do is better
thank you
just the the very end
of that song the venom
in her voice play time's over
oh god it's so good thoughts on scott
pilgrim without thinking about the
ending okay setting the ending aside
i have a little trouble vibing with the
fact that these people actually die
in these fights i
like i know it's in its internal logic
and they can set whatever rules they
want
that never sat well with me like that
these people are actually dead
but look here's the main thing visually
it's a stunning film
it is an amazing realization um of
integrating both comic book and video
game elements into a movie
it's it's it's a stunning film
i've still got a lot of nitpicks on it
though even setting the ending aside
and just to reiterate for folks who are
new around here the ending of scott
pilgrim versus the world is [ __ ]
uh the sex doctor video killed the radio
star
would you ever record a christmas album
i don't think i like enough
christmas songs
um and i'm always i'm always more
partial to
the older style carols you know carol
the bells
um we three kings things like that
ah
i don't know when it'll go up end of the
month or start of next month but
if you listen to um the what the frail
podcast
that i do with jesse gender about
farscape um
the episode talking about
uh dream a little dream which will be
later uh i mentioned there
what i put in my eggnog
plugging my podcast speed i am on a roll
tonight
top level accountant um
can you do a cross-eyed face can i do a
cross-eyed face
uh that was a little more than you asked
for but
i'm having fun at this point so you go
on about singing
uh out of fear of being demonetized then
and then you say
the s word like here's the thing saying
it once
in what's going to be uh over an hour
long stream
i'll get away with it you really only
get demonetized for swearing like
right at the start of a video or doing
it profusely across the entire thing
i want a compilation of your angry rants
on a record
oh well i've got i've got the playlist
of my angriest rants i feel like
somebody could cut together a super cut
of my angriest moments
like when i'm red-faced and like ah
i i'm not gonna do it i don't have the
time but like if somebody wants a
project
have at it whenever i listen to trans
siberian orchestra version of carol the
bells i think of you
oh that's so good like i even love the
traditional
version of carol the best but oh the
trans-siberian orchestra oh
oh i love that all the people asking you
to listen to doctor in distress should
also be asking you to react to
dimensions in time ah
that has also been um requested
not as frequently but it's come up
uh it's like a pg-13 movie you're
allowed one f-bomb pirates i was
actually gonna make that
same comparison so
uh eggy water yes yes
uh i was going to attempt something
similar uh but with your cold opens
oh god the cold open gags
oh some of them are so bad
like like if i actually
stopped and thought about what i was
doing because like i most
a lot of videos i don't script at all at
this point on this channel
a decent amount of them i'm at least
working off notes
but i never i almost never
think to script an opening gag i just
sit down i'm like
uh and then it's like first or second
thing off
my head that's why they're so all over
the place do you celebrate st
patrick's day not really
i've got i've got a little irish
in the mix but like i'm mostly english
so like if i were to do what is
traditional for my family
lineage on st patrick's day i would just
go about oppressing everybody
so although i think some of you might
like that
remember my life as a teenage robot i
remember it
existing
that's about that that's about it yeah i
get that them dying and scott pilgrim
never really sat well with me either but
it satisfied my bloodlust so hey ho
hey you know that's that's valid love
your videos
uh but you need to turn the light down a
little because it's making your face and
hands bright
bright white at this point i'm too lazy
to go and adjust the thing
so just deal with the fact that i'm a
ghost
i don't know what i'm doing hey carowind
did i miss something
i see i see you getting my attention or
did did i
did i cause reactions
sorry not sorry sorry not sorry about
what i
said that one okay
good to know uh
i'd avoid the sequel to six the tone
gets so much darker
uh and the detectives that follows
aren't nearly as good at singing or
dancing oh
no like part of what's great about six
is how
just over the top and flamboyant it is
like some of the material is a bit dark
but
uh i think you caused reactions
good to know
so proud of elliot paige yes i i
addressed that early in the stream
but i saw it come up a few times since
then yeah i'm
i'm happy for him i wish him the best of
luck
with the ass hats that will come out of
the woodwork because they all they
always do but
i i'm happy for him
one thing about santa carla he never
could stomach all the damn vampires
i've been to the boardwalk where that
movie was shot
i've ridden on the big dipper it's a
good boardwalk
uh i have a youtube movie reviewer
friend
uh who's abysmal at doing comedy
openings you've got it down to a fine
art
i i would debate that but you know what
i'll just i'll just
i'll shut up and take the compliment
yeah
um bennett's the say bennett the sage
is a guy uh who you used to work for
who used to work for channel awesome but
now his stuff has gotten really good
after leaving well
i feel like everybody who's left there
their stuff got better after leaving
because
they didn't have to mimic doug's
format so much like
if you if you i mean well goodness sake
lindsey ellis has really branched out
and done her own thing linkara hasn't
changed drastically but he kind of
nailed down
his thing um while he was still there
um but you know even someone like todd
in the shadows who hasn't changed his
format but
has has come more into his own voice
as opposed to kind of trying to be the
musical equivalent of doug walker
his new stuff's better it just is
can you rap guns and ships no
i trip over my tongue trying to do that
uh
rank the three main deaths at the end of
raiders of the lost ark
um here's the thing
i don't remember them that well without
my head because when i was a little kid
i always hit my eyes during that part
so it's not ingrained in my head like
the rest of it
i feel like the melt is the most iconic
out of the three though
speaking of lindsey ellis only any
thoughts on the sequel video to the
omega vs fiasco
wow right
holy cow okay so
for anyone who doesn't follow lindsay
ellis
which you should she's amazing but
anyways
she did a piece talking about oh god how
do i even
uh how do i even discuss this
so in the in the world of online
supernatural erotica
there is a sub-genre generally called
omega-verse and without getting into all
the tropes of it
it's it's mail on mail
usually um dubious consent
uh taking a lot of cues from the
misunderstanding that people have about
wolf packs alphas betas omegas and so
forth and i'm not going to get into any
any more of the specifics about it
but apparently there is a writer in that
subgenre who is
very very fond of issuing
um what have proven and have been
alleged to be
i gotta be careful about how i talk
about this um
spurious or questionable uh dmca
takedowns of other authors work
claiming that she that it's infringing
on her copyright
now her understanding of copyright seems
to be
very badly skewed because by and large
she
she cites tropes and you can't copyright
a trope
you can copyright a character you can
copyright a specific plot you can't
copyright a trope
that's not how anything works but
lindsay ellis did a video
covering some of the shenanigans that
went on there
and was then hit with threat of a
lawsuit and dmca
take downs for her video because in a
40-minute video
she read a couple of paragraphs of this
woman's work amounting to about two
minutes
and this woman claims that it is
therefore a copyright violation which
again to my understanding
as a layperson not a legal expert not
illegal anything
that's not how anything works
the follow like the initial video was
already like
what the follow-up
is madness
it's amazing like even if you don't
normally watch your stuff
watch these two videos because it's
incredible
uh bennett pretty much does reviews on
older anime like 80s and 90s kind of
stuff uh
he's even done a new series called uh
old
daku new tricks where he gives his
thoughts on newer anime
i like that title i'm not sure i'm into
anime enough to get that much out of it
but sounds interesting
i actually like nostalgic critic but i
did discover the channel after all the
controversy occurred
i mean like i stopped watching because i
wasn't comfortable watching him anymore
i'm not gonna say that he wasn't good at
what he did
i enjoyed him i was subscribed so
you know when i say things like
um he kind of felt like he was
restraining the other creators
i'm not saying that and like imposing
his format on them i'm not saying that
the format didn't work for him it did
but it really did feel like he he wanted
um uh he wanted other reviewers to
basically be
the version of him that talked about
comics or music
or more girly things or
video games or what have you
not illegal anything has been been bad
have
have i been bad
today
uh do you like being the center of
attention
um sometimes
i tend to describe myself as an
extroverted introvert
if i am comfortable and to be clear i am
capable of being comfortable on a stage
but if i'm comfortable yeah i do like
attention
but you can't just drop me into the
middle of a party
and have me be okay i'll actually be
really uncomfortable
so uh there's a i have a lot of clashing
dual nature
go freaking figure different elements of
myself
trying to balance each other and it's
it's a little bit of a
i don't know result huge shock
i've always said show me a line and i
will straddle it are you an extrovert or
introvert
both are you man or a woman
that's that's that's my life
ain't it fun
i have a weird position i'm
anti-imperialist yet if we got invaded
by aliens i would be down for it
um
i mean it depends on the aliens um
and whether they require a coordinated
response or not
because i would be kind of tempted to
say just arm everybody and have
and let's let's uh uh
anarchy guerrilla warfare this thing
wreck-it ralph would be hero 6
wreck-it ralph be here 6 is very good
but i like rico ralph better
i've gone a bit long today i'm i'm
having fun
um i do need to stop soon though because
i am
uh i i do have stuff i need to shoot
i was gonna i'm i was gonna try and do
some more editing i'm not gonna get that
done
um why do you say my cavity in a
high-pitched voice
um as an exaggeration of what idris elba
actually does in cats
because he doesn't pitch up as much as i
pitch up
because i'm not sure he's capable of
pitching up quite to my level
i love you ildras but um i don't think
he can get here
but his voice does go up a bit then more
than his standard for him
when he does that um i know what you're
saying i can't imagine how patronizing
uh ellis must have found the nostalgia
chick moniker
i mean to be fair when she first started
she basically like
they had an opening for what was going
to be the nostalgia chick
she had to go through like an audition
process um
where she was so like she knew what she
was getting into
but i have no doubt that she eventually
wanted to grow out of that and because
very clearly she has
since branching out on her own what are
your thoughts on revenge of the nerds
really rapey but then again so are a lot
of
80s college sex comedies
um i mean that's okay i appreciate what
it was doing at the time
uh i kind of hate that a lot of uh it's
gotten better
lately but for a while a lot of geek
culture or supposed geek culture was
just doing revenge of the nerds again
and was treading on those same
stereotypes i mean it's one of many
many many many many many many many many
many many
many reasons why i hate big bang theory
you say it like that because there's no
other way of saying the cavity
you're sexy and you know it on uh
on a good day i know it and um
i'm having a good day veers review
really rapey two stars
[Laughter]
uh how would you
change the character fagan and oliver
why would i change him
i've played him that was where i got the
theater bug
was playing fagin in seventh grade
with fingerless gloves and
um like stippled on
facial hair
ah that was a lot of fun
i think i better think it out again
oh oh man that takes me back
uh do you get drunk on st patrick's day
if i do it's by coincidence
not by intent
really rapey two stars without a say
word seven stars with a safe word
well if there's a safe word then it's
not rape it's uh consensual non-consent
that's a whole other ball of wax i was
getting close to 3 a.m over here
seriously
to hell with time zones see you guys
around peace see you logan thanks for
stopping in
uh my friend recently showed me my hero
academia
it was the first time a movie made me
feel like i was tripping since scott
pilgrim
from what i've heard about that show and
i i doubt the movie is much different
i'm that sounds accurate late in the
stream how do you feel about ellen page
coming out as trans and
is now uh elliott page power to him
i'm i'm very happy for him i'm glad he
came out i hope he has to deal with this
little bull crap as possible but there
will be some
uh i know your daughter knows about your
gender fluidity but out of curiosity
does she know the term gender fluid and
other non-binary gender identities
uh i don't believe she does like the
thing is
i haven't had to have many like
sit down and go over things
conversations with her
because this is
just kind of her day-to-day reality
i mean she saw me go in full feminine
makeup for the first time when she was
two years old
and this was by design
her mother and i made the decision that
she actually watched me she
watched me put on the makeup she watched
me put on the wig so that she
knew it was me and so that
at a young age she would understand that
no matter
what's going on here
but i'm still her father i'm the same
person
and so for her my
fluctuating presentation and even going
more feminine and
and all of this like this is not that
far from what's always been her normal
and her normal is
her father is going to look different at
different times on different days and
i'm still the same person
so when she gets a little older
i might have more concrete conversations
with her just to get a sense of what she
does know and then fill in some of the
gaps
but like she's also nine
so it's hard to know to what
to what degree i i can expect her to
wrap her head around all this
but as far as like her dealing with me
i'm still her dad i'm still just her dad
who annoys her
and she thinks is weird not because of
this just because
she thinks her mother's weird too so
there you go alec guinness played fagin
in david lean's film version in the 40s
the makeup he's wearing is
yeah he played uh quite a few ethnic
minorities for lean
oh i heard about that um
sony is making a silhouette
wow okay that's a sign i need to stop
soon sony's making a cinderella movie
what are your thoughts i have none
it's a public domain story go ahead
whatever
i don't really care
is the term father at all dysphoric for
you for me personally no
um this question came up on tick tock
not long ago
but for some parents
who transition after their
children are born there is the potential
for dysphoria
depending on what terms their
children use to refer to them now in my
case because my dysphoria is
so mild it's so incredibly minor to the
point that i
barely acknowledge that i have any at
all
i will always be her father
even if i transition full-time as a
woman
and go exclusively by feminine pronouns
i will still be her father
i'm not her mother i didn't give birth
to her
my part in her life is as a father
and the nature of my relationship with
her
doesn't change even if i do
i'm i've been dad all her life will
always be
now again that's me and me only there
are
transparents who do have dysphoria and
who prefer other terms so don't take
what
i'm saying as um the way to handle it
with anybody else
but that's me i am her father
she's stuck with me
uh i really should i really should wrap
up
as long as we normalize it queer
identities aren't going to be
uh weirder to kids than any of the other
stuff we teach them yeah that's what i
figure
uh there is it actually sequel to six
i'm sorry i misled you
uh
uh you are her parent the love is there
regardless of what labels
you and her are comfortable with yeah
but like
that's the label that's what it is what
it's been it's what it's going to be
because it's important to me that she
always understand that i
am the same person
and again speaking only for myself i
feel like in some ways asking her to
call me anything other than
her father would be
that that would actually represent a
much more fundamental change
than anything that's happened to me in
terms of my presentation
or the fact that i have breasts now or
any of that
that would actually mean something has
changed about our relationship but
nothing has
and it won't not on that front
uh hi dave i'm actually wrapping it up
so let's see here
yeah this this is your last chance to
get in
questions or super chats or what have
you what are your thoughts on treasure
planet
i really like treasure planet now
granted i was always going to be sucker
for that because i actually really like
treasure island
it's one of the classics i actually
enjoy
i'm a real sucker for that story and so
i i think treasure plants an
unappreciated gem
i enjoy it a lot uh the film ending of
oliver with fagin
and dodger walking off into the sunlight
together is much better than the stage
ending
oh yeah it's yeah
stage ending is a bit more melancholy
do you do squats um i've tried
um i like i get good about keeping it up
for like a few weeks and then i drop off
it again
that's like me and most exercise at this
point
oh stretch my back
okay i i do need to wrap it up so thank
you everybody for
um tuning in i hope that you
have a good rest of the week and
um yeah stay safe
stay well be kind
oh do you have a favorite star trek
character oh
bookworm i don't know if i could um
if i could pick a single one like i'm
partial to data
um i like picard
i like mccoy
i think i've kind of got a three-way tie
going on there anyways i gotta wrap it
up
so please remember you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned mccabe